now this guy they got they got storm the
capital energy they are so upset we go
and they actually killed the guy they
put weights until he died they killed
him they yeah they put a hook
though yeah
especially not if you're dealing with
that [ __ ] yeah nowhere and he's stepping
on his toe
that County's prosecution they said
they're gonna try to go for a felony
because I'm still a lot of money so they
could go you're going to prison
police come
on
yeah how much does this yeah but it'll
be a mermaid
why am I dressed like half the guys in
this video that's all right
well look at how much look at how
like visceral the responses are oh
they're Furious
the last time I got this upset is when
they thought Trump this is like
elections right this is like any sort of
like weird sport yeah but why didn't
they check wait hold on
but why why didn't they check earlier
he's been doing it for years for a few
tournaments and then they had suspicions
like man how's this fish so heavy
nobody's that they're like 50 pounds and
he kept winning though that it's a lot
they got greedy how about this don't
have fishing competitions just go fish
not stupid because they like money yeah
they get it they're getting ripped off
because it's so easy to cheat they put a
[ __ ] one pound weight and a fish's
anus no they put they put uh an actual
like fillet into them and they did both
he pulls out he goes a filet oh what's
wrong with you how could you do this
it's Pride he's all bass don't eat
fillets wow you have a fish fillet from
McDonald's [ __ ]
with the wrapper in it it happened this
is an adult happy meal